in other news the Prime Minister has
arrived in Japan ahead of this week's G7
Summit he's expected to sign a deal with
Japan to cooperate on defense and Share
technology the Prime Minister has said
key points of discussion at the summit
will include Ukraine the indo-pacific
region and economic growth this region
is going to be increasingly important to
our economic prospects at home if you
look at where Global growth is going to
come from Over the coming decades the
indo-pacific region is going to be
increasingly important after this I'm
heading to me Japanese Business Leaders
who are announcing 18 billion pounds
worth of new investment into the UK
that's going to support and create jobs
that's in Tokyo for us hi Beth good
morning good afternoon where you are a
deal with Japan what's that going to
look like
well you just saw the Prime Minister
that a naval base as he was saying he's
then going to a business Leader's lunch
it's all part of a whistle-stop tour of
Tokyo before he heads to Hiroshima to
talk about this Hiroshima Accord now
this is a dealer strengthening of
cooperation and ties between our two
Nations between Japan and the UK and it
will cover defense technology and also
security and economy when it comes to
defense uh the UK are going to confirm
that the UK's carriers strike route for
example that's our some of our Fleet of
naval ships we'll do a tour of the
indo-pacific region again in 2025 when
it comes to economic investment and
economic agreement the Prime Minister
there talking about 18 billion pounds of
inward Investments which he says will
create more jobs in the UK and then of
course on technology at the UK and Japan
want to develop uh
semiconductors this is because much of
the world's production happens in Taiwan
we're over dependent on a handful of
countries given the China threat there's
a sense both from Japan and the UK that
they need to diversify their supply
chains so another billion pound deal on
that so these are all things that he's
doing ahead of traveling to Hiroshima
this evening where he will sign the
Accord officially with the Japanese
Premier and then they'll get down to
business talking about what they should
do in their approach to China Ukraine
and of course economic growth
been talking about migration if I'm not
mistaken the manifesto promise was 250
000 what's he saying about that now
yeah very interesting on the plane over
the prime minister's obviously been
focusing a lot on illegal illegal
migration going to the Council of Europe
trying to get more cooperation from
European Partners to help him fulfill
that pledge about trying to stop Small
Boat Crossings in order to drive down
illegal migration on the matter of legal
migration refusing to recommit to
Manifesto promises made back in 2019
let's have a little listen to what he
had to say about that this morning
while Manifesto did commit us to
reducing levels of net migration I
remain committed to that goal I want to
bring down the levels of legal migration
and alongside that I'm also as everybody
knows hugely focused on stopping the
boat because illegal migration is a
topic that is concerning I think almost
everyone in our country and I'm working
night and day to stop the boat
so in the 2019 Manifesto the
conservative party promised to bring
overall numbers of net migration down
now in 2019 net migration stood at 226
000 it's now running at half a million
so you can see why in pragmatic terms
the prime minister is simply not going
to recommit to that commitment because
he simply can't deliver it as one of his
allies said to me the other day he will
only promise what he can deliver and he
will not make promises on things he
can't deliver and look next week net
migration is set to rise to 650 up to 1
million so it is a burgeoning problem
for the government and it is driving
cabinet splits back home the Home
Secretary swella bravamans is publicly
say we need to bring net migration down
before the next general election Jeremy
Hunt the chancellor it seems the Prime
Minister too a slightly different
approach because they need migration in
order to help Drive
economic growth and deal with labor
shortages so a problem at home that's
following him over here